welcome everyone to my talk on
complex-valued Raziel ization I'm kernel
developer in the visualization team and
today I'll be showing you some of the
plots that we've been adding to the
Wolfram language to visualize complex
functions so the first slide here I've
actually mean you just skip over that so
this is the list of functions that I'll
be showing you today so I split them up
into two groups the first five functions
are the ones that we've already added to
version 12 of Mathematica and the rest
of them we are working on them to really
soon so there are nine of these
functions and I won't have time to go
into all aspects of these functions so
what I did is I added a few resources in
this slights so there are three links
the first link will take you to what's
new in Mathematica 12-page so for every
major release of Mathematica we put
together examples to show off some of
the features new features that we've
added and so this link will take you
directly to the page on complex
visualization and so it has a bunch of
examples and you can drill down on any
given examples and it'll show you the
application it'll show you the code
snippets and it will talk about the
function and the options related to the
function the other two links here are
for the talks that we've given in the
past year about this functionality so
the first one is a talk that Brett
champion gave on Twitch earlier this
year which actually talks you through
some of the examples on
the what's new in complex visualization
page and the second the third link is my
own talk from last year's tech
conference in which I showed the first
group of functions so I got a little bit
more time to go into them then I
probably will in this talk so with the
with that I can so yeah so one more
thing to say is that these are handy and
convenient functions that we have added
and we built them on top of existing
visualization functions so in the naming
scheme should give you some idea of what
the underlying function is and most of
the options that work for the underlying
function should also work for the
complex variant of that plot and in
cases where we need it to do something
special with the input then we've added
new options for these plots and I will I
will point them out to you as we go
along okay so with that I can jump into
the functions the first one is complex
lists plot and it's probably the
simplest one and it takes in a list of
complex numbers and it plots them on the
axes so here we generate a table of
complex numbers by plugging in some
values into the zeta function and plot
the real part on the x-axis and the
imaginary part on the y-axis and so we
get this familiar looking plot of the of
the complex numbers along the critical
line so complex lists plot is built on
top of list plot and so you can use
options like joined and scaling
functions and they will still behave
like you would expect them to
so the next two plots are re-employed
and abs art plot and these plots take a
complex functions and and do a few
things with them to plot them so reading
plot plots the both the real and the
imaginary parts of the function so while
plot of a function like this will just
give you the real part of the of the
function re-employed plots both the real
and the imaginary parts and it styles
them differently and so if you look at
something like plot legends this
automatically knows that there are two
parts to this plot and it splits the
legend you know nicely for you to be
able to differentiate between the two
parts and I'm also overlaying these
plots with the with the roots of the
zeta function using epilogue but the two
options to note here are real Abel's an
dream style which are new options for
re-employed which give you better
control over styling and labeling both
the parts that are the outputs to this
function
abs are plot we'll take the function and
it'll plot the absolute value of the
function and then it will color the
function based on its arguments so if
you look at the legend on the right side
of the plot it will give you the key to
read the color that is bleeped being
plotted in the plot so so the bottom
function with plots Ahriman Z as you saw
in this one it's for the for this
specific int but it's purely it's purely
real and so there is no imaginary part
to that function and so that's probably
a bit easier to read here there only two
colors going on and you can pick the
colors and figure out what the argument
is for that plot the top one is
obviously the zeta function which has
more variation next plot is complex plot
this is a plot that is on a complex
plane and it takes the complex function
and plot set and and it does a couple of
things so first let's talk about the
color it colors the function based on
its argument obviously you know just
like for apps apps art plot you can read
off the argument based on the color if
you have this kind of a coloring scheme
it's so happens that we can also pick
out some important features of the plot
based on how the color changes on any
given point and so that's what the
thumbnails across the top are showing
you so there are a few features I did
silly if we look at the first one which
is a 0 so that arrow the white arrow is
showing you the direction in which the
colors are changing for this particular
color scheme so if we start off with the
color that is corresponding to
the minimum of the argument on the
legend the right-hand side of the legend
and then go around starts off with that
sort of turquoise ee sort of color and
then it goes all the way around to the
cyan ish car and so if you look at the
legend you can see the both endpoints
the bottom and the top and then if we
figure out which way in which direction
the colors are changing so that's sort
of changing in the counter clockwise in
which tells you that there is zero at
that point and if you look at if you
skip one and look at the pole the
addition of that cycle changes and now
the colors are changing in a clockwise
direction so that's how you you can pick
out zeros and poles if you have multiple
zeros and multiple so they they will
change the color multiple times
depending on how many zeros and poles
there are you can do that with with the
labeling option for yeah and so yeah the
final one is a singularity where the
color cycles get faster if you will as
you move towards the the point at which
the rarity so in the thumbnail you start
from the bottom left as you go up to the
top right as you approach the point the
the color cycle sort of infinite number
of times and then you so come out on the
other side so that's with a color so you
plot the function you color it by the
argument and then we also sort of put
another layer on top which is a shading
pattern and so you kind of see that in
this plot with the the corners on the
left side where you know you see the the
white where it's you know the its
starting a clip and so after the
as applied the shadings applied based on
the absolute value of the function and
so for the second example for riemann z
i have specified a shading pattern that
is not the default by default its shades
based on the absolute value and i've
specified a different one and the way to
specify this is using the color function
option which takes a list in which the
first part is the color function and the
second one is the pattern that you want
to apply and so we have a few of these
named patterns which are in the
documentation and so I picked this
cyclical log ABS and this gives as an
opportunity to look at the second part
of the legend on the right so the legend
split into two parts the right side
gives you the colors for the argument
and the left side shows you the pattern
that is being applied based on whatever
scheme we pick so in this case we think
the cyclic log app so it applies the
pattern based on the log of the absolute
value so you can see the log scale there
and it'll show you sort of where the
cycles happen based on some criteria
complex plot 3d is last plot in this in
this group of plots and this is very
similar to complex plot with just the
difference that now we have an extra
axis to plot the absolute value so we go
ahead and plot the absolute value
directly on the z axis and we don't do
not have any shading and so here I'm
doing the same thing as in the previous
plot but we have the absolute value
being plotted on the z axis
and apply and I'm applying scaling
function log to sort of smooth out some
of the features so that we get a good
sense of what's going on with the
functions
that completes the first group of
functions that I showed you this is the
second group which we are working on and
the first one is complex region plot
which is very similar to region plots so
it plots the region where the predicate
is true and so in this case we are
plotting the regions where the imaginary
parts of the function are positive we
are also adding complex versions of
stream and vector plots where the
functions take the complex function and
plot the the vector fields and so if you
went to Brett's talk this morning he
talked a little bit about the
improvements we were making to vector
plot and so we inherit those into
complex vector plot so here you can see
the riemann z function where we're we're
plotting the vector field and you can
get some idea of what what the function
is doing so here the the sizes of the
vectors are constant the argument you
can sort of figure out based on the
angle of the of the vectors and then
it's being colored based on on the norm
and so it will give you some sense of
what the what the function is doing so
the final set of plots here are complex
contour plots and so we have the same
sort of function here so this plots the
contours for the values of the function
that is being plotted and so here we
have the imaginary plot part of the
function the contours for the imaginary
part of the function that are being
plotted and we've introduced a new color
function called balanced hue for complex
plots
to sort of balance out the the variation
in some of these values which also looks
nice so complex contour plot has another
trick up its sleeve which is that if you
give it a list of functions it will plot
the contours for both functions so you
have the Ryo of Zeta and imaginary of
theta here and the real imaginary for
for the riemann z and it'll plot both
the contours together and so in this
configuration it does not sort of fill
between the contour lines with any color
too so as to minimize the visual clutter
that happens if you have these layering
of colors but you still get the idea of
what the functions are doing and so it's
an easy and good way to compare two or
more functions at the same time so i
want to close out my talk by showing you
a couple of plots so this is the sort of
the 2d extension if you will of the
re-employed that i've shown you earlier
on so we're plotting the zeta function
the contours based on the absolute value
of the zeta function we are applying a
scaling function to it you know we're
applying the new color function then
we're overlaying that with the the roots
of the zeta function the non trivial
roots of the zeta function can see that
line up with critical strip and the same
thing with the riemann z and for these
functions the roots of the zeta function
the roots coincide so that's it's a nice
way this is also sort of the famous
contour plot from the Riemann zeta
poster if you are aware of that and this
is
the complex plot 3d version of that and
so the absolute value is plotted on the
z axis
and you know we are applying the the log
function you can see the the ridges
nicely for the zeta and we are
overlaying again with the there's the
Ritz for for the zeta so I think that's
the end of my talk yeah so yeah so this
is just to highlight the point that when
we look at complex contour plot this is
really a mapping from complex to real
not from complex to complex so you
always have to well most of the time you
have to have a function that will give
you good values for the contours on the
real if you want sort of the traditional
mapping for complex plots this you'd
still have used we can still use per
metric plot this is the sort of
conformal mapping for the zeta function
and this is the old-fashioned way of
sort of doing the same thing
we don't have a complex version of the
parametric plot yet but I just put in
this slide to highlight that point there
and so yeah I think I'll end my talk
there and thank you
[Applause]